here we go season 3 get the crew back
together
oh look who we found here the world's
favorite cinnamon roll Adam and drew
what's up man what is that shirt let's
talk about this is a great shirt this is
fashion see now you got a shirt now you
got a dark hole oh love in the stuff
gross all right mac and cheese let's go
Niki's let's go welcome back boys today
on worth it we're back for season 3
we're gonna try three different macaroni
and cheeses at three drastically
different price points to find out which
one is the most worth it at its price
macaroni and cheese this was it worth it
Oh worth it little rusty here
kids love mac and cheese I love mac and
cheese I'm not a kid you kind of are
we're on our way to chef Maryland it's a
soul food spa expectations hi well let's
not delay wait hard oh okay you're still
rolling no it's not
welcome on chef Marilyn all right how
are you well today I'm gonna make my
macaroni and cheese and then hopefully
you'll be able to sample some of the
other food that we have on the line yeah
how did you get your start in cooking as
a youngster I didn't cook I just think I
was too cute to cook I just started
cooking at my house and people were
coming everybody wanted plate and before
you know it I had opened up a restaurant
and we walked into your restaurant this
is the friendliest staff I've ever seen
well my roots are Louisiana and coming
out here to California my parents never
want us to lose our southern hospitality
I'd love to make people happy and if it
can be through your stomach to have a
soul food restaurant you have to have
macaroni and cheese greens and yams my
macaroni and cheese people love it they
go crazy oh and it's a real simple
recipe you boil the macaroni and then I
use cheddar cheese and I use Monterey
Jack and then American cheese with
canned milk I'll put about twenty six
cans just to make it milky and creamy
and then Laury Laury just icky no salt
no pepper none of that it's just real
simple and then you put it in the oven
and it melts itself I used to have to
melt the cheese and the butter and
everything else takes too long this way
I can keep the Mac coming
you can Mac comment the comment and
expertise I love that too the first meal
of the seasons whoo that is random Wow
it is a straight-up lollipop how's yours
it's great I don't want it all righty
oh yeah we both got mac and cheese we
both got greens
we got the fried chicken but I threw in
a piece of wasps tail we agreed to get
the same thing I know but agreements are
made to be broken
all right let's eat oh yeah you're gonna
get there the crud to the bite right
there
mmm slightly overcooked right there on
the end
worth it season three Cheers
it's the good stuff dreamy it is very
creamy
that's dreamy oh there's a lot of
different cheeses happening in there and
you look inside here look at that
what is la dirar and the cheese melted
on the interior of a macaroni
I love the slightly overdone cheese
parts that's my favorite all about that
crusty cheese interplaying with the
creamy cheese oh it's really mac and
cheese his job to play second fiddle to
a lot of foods I think everything's
playing second fiddle to this mac and
cheese today really yeah
impression Maryland even though she did
give me a hug and she rubbed my belly I
don't know where it came from
she said god I believe it chef Maryland
keeping it tight in the kitchen
boom banana pudding
ah well chef maryland's my soul is
satisfied my favorite part was watching
her hack open 26 cans of milk
Maggi juice back we have vector oniy and
cheese rat box mac and cheese came out
in 1937 during the Great Depression one
box of mega cheese can serve up to four
people not to mention each box was
nineteen cents and way over my mind all
right so we're on our way now to the
little jewel of New Orleans which is in
the heart of Chinatown here in Los
Angeles so or on to your horses because
Yankee Doodle here we go this is the
little jewel of New Orleans
we specialize in cuisine of New Orleans
Louisiana my home to our business model
is sort of the old-style bodegas where
you would have a grocery and then also a
kitchen that we cook some of the same
stuff that was available at the shops
today we're gonna have something from
our hot plates a special menu which is a
crow mac and cheese deluxe it's a cheesy
format not so much immaculately a cheese
but a rotini pasta it's done in a cheese
sauce of course you're gonna start off
with a lot of sauteed garlic onion
Creole seasonings is heavy cream many
cheese's we like to impart the crawfish
tails blend it into the sauce and this
is sauteed slow and low for a long time
period garnish with red onions lots of
hot sauce lots of cheese we try to get a
zesty as possible that would be the word
that I would put here we make our own
in-house smoked andouille sausage and we
grill that and it's topped with
blackened shrimp so this is a very rich
dish that almost always people feel
guilty about finishing but somehow do
so we got these root beers which you can
get by just walking over to a case
picking them out and then popping a
bottle cap off the wall root beer is
delightful and underrated in observation
for you guess what we got here Ruby here
made with pure Louisiana king sugar what
do we have here
trapeze Louisiana original recipe hot
sauce yes we are in a Louisiana pond can
we start let's go oh I can smell the
cayenne really well in the milk that's
not an ingredient to get excited about
all the milk if you want to get some mac
and cheese this weekend I'm craving some
milk mmm you all ready for this that is
some next-level mac it's less creamy and
more like saucy there are so many
flavors going on right now probably the
most prominent ones the hot sauce it's
instantly biting through the heaviness
of that cheese sauce
zesty is chef Maryland's my extol what
satisfied ya here my soul is flirting
with the devil exactly I feel like
sinner eating this I think I do
gentleman in a little way it reminds me
of Cincinnati skyline chili
it's spaghetti chili cheese with onions
on top yeah that's you nailed it
this could actually be kicked up a
little bit for me don't worry no this
could actually be good oh we couldn't
know it could never be good I swear to
god yeah
scrumptious right I very much enjoyed
that macaroni and cheese me too man me
too
reckon she's attack backed better not be
cheesy the world record for the largest
macaroni and cheese how big do you think
it was I'm going with 1 million pounds a
million pounds a million pounds okay
you're wrong one pound this isn't the
prices right
the largest macaroni and cheese ever was
in New Orleans Louisiana 2010 and it
weighed at two thousand four hundred and
sixty nine pounds not bad but why well
if you love something the best way to
represent that love is to amass a lot of
it so you love your girlfriend right
that I do very much so you just need to
get the largest amount of your
girlfriend great so where we going now
we are going to Barton jeans
[Music]
I'm executive chef the Atilla Baalak
here at Barton G in Los Angeles and
today we're gonna make truffled lobster
macaroni and cheese in a five pound loss
inside a lobster stuffed to the gills no
pun intended
Barton is a event planner extraordinaire
and basically his vision is just pushing
the bounds of imagination with every way
that we present food it's gonna serve
about two to four people at about a
hundred and ninety five dollars you ask
me to pay that much morning for mac and
cheese an immediate response would be no
no way couple to be lobster five pound
Maine lobster poached in an aromatic
broth right here in-house we're gonna
use a power tool to carve out two sides
and directly down the backside of the
lobster to kind of open that up like a
hatch and remove all the delicious and
succulent meat from the inside of there
we used Maine lobsters here we just
noticed that you know they have an
inherit sweetness to them and to us it's
pretty much the standard in quality and
then we're gonna fold in a really nice
creamy and decadent cheese sauce with
cave aged Gruyere a beautiful Vermont
cheddar and then to that we add nice
aged parm and cotija cheese for like a
bite of salinity add the lobster meat
back in there we're gonna put a heap of
preserved truffles in there stuff it all
right back in and we're gonna coat it
with some brown butter bread crumbs some
added cheese bake it and then shower in
a coating of Perigord truffles like the
finest the market can get pretty much we
put it that way yeah yes fYI this is a
virgin cocktail so no alcohol I'm
driving but you my friend what jealous
boom yeah that here's my friend monkey
time
hmm I'm kind of into it you know cool
like you think about this monstrosity
that you're dropping 200 bucks for
you're not just getting dinner you're
getting dinner on the show well I love
about the presentation is that it served
on a baking sheet you have this
extravagant thing and the best way to
eat it is just on the thing that cooked
it and that's fun that's fun
should we just go yeah we should oh look
at that the trifecta
this is insane what are we doing I don't
know what you're doing season to season
turkey Oh
excellent noodle shape one of my
favorite noodle shapes this corkscrew is
the perfect cheese trap
you just ate Lobster I need no trouble
and you're focused on the macaroni
aspect this is a macaroni and cheese
episode I'm gonna focus on the macaroni
this is the most intense dish I've maybe
ever eaten all lobster is not that
strong of a flavor but then the truffle
looks like somebody's just like throwing
grenades my mouth of joy mac and cheese
is making me party no I'm a little bit
like that's Tom you say it's been a long
day tasty oh wow
that was an insane amount of truffle I'm
more interested in the cheese honestly
where's he getting that cheese so Andrew
yeah which mac and cheese was the most
worth it I just get impressed
barring jeez was not as ridiculous as I
thought it would be you are getting a
very fanciful experience so far Jeter
with a winner no little jewels my worth
it yeah yeah no yeah it was a crazy
tasting mac and cheese Barton G's for
what you're getting is actually a value
it's crazy to say that but you're
getting a value that lobster dish feeds
four maybe five maybe six I think you
could stretch it it is that risk you
little jewel then Dewey sausage and
doing it for you doing it for me
my was a winner is chef Marilyn you're
getting not only a great value but the
hospitality the love you getting chef
Marilyn Evan which one would you choose
all right that's it for episode one we
got nine hot some cold episodes coming
right at you maybe go over to different
countries time around the down under and
then to the Japan all right this is
super close cut now this is kind of
making it
thanks for watching if you want more
worth to content we've actually got a
whole brand new spinoff show but worth
it lifestyle it's on Bucky blue right
now see you there
oh oh yes